Nancy Pelosi comes out on stage and the
the liberal stronghold of New York City
and The Crowd Goes Nuts screaming the
video is hilarious because a guy's like
it's Nancy Pelosi why is everybody
booing seriously
oh yeah but the best part was like you
can hear some of the women booing and
it's very high pitched like boom and I'm
like everyone is the boo you can really
hear the tones here yeah now this is
good news look it's because this should
be kind of a white pill in that
everybody hates Nancy Pelosi so at least
there's that like what if everything
ends with the left and the right holding
hands and singing about how much they
hate Chuck Schumer Pelosi Nadler yeah I
think that people really dislike
oligarchy and oligarchs in control of
our government it's not even who it's if
an oligarch gets in there or someone
gets in there and then becomes an
oligarch like she's been well allegedly
making all sorts of money off stock
trades I've never seen the data to prove
it but this is what I've heard we don't
want people like I don't want people
like that in charge that are going to
sell country people she makes better
stocks trades than Warren Buffett